so much jillian we will check back in
with you later on in the show
now it's time to spice up your summer at
daylight beach club's neon vibra a
weekly latin-themed night swim party so
let's welcome general manager nick
palichia to the show for all the details
how are you very good thank you so much
for having us oh please we're excited to
spread the word about this yeah no thank
you uh we started the party a few weeks
ago and it's been um a great success so
far uh we really look forward to that
success rolling forward um it's actually
a neon themed uh latin night swim party
and uh we really encourage anyone that
comes out to see these great local latin
djs um that we have
dj's latin performers but everybody is
invited yeah and it's mostly like
mainstream latin music so it's a party
for everybody and um
you know most importantly we encourage
everyone to wear neon when they come and
really get into the theme
we've got uh face painters and body
painters there to help out with that and
we also have our go-go dancers and all
the decorations and stuff i love it so
it's like vegas culture meets latin
culture it's a mash-up it's so much fun
um now what inspired you guys at
daylight to bring this to the strip
because this is one of the only
you know latin themed parties on the
strip yeah we've just felt like there
was a real need for this this type of a
party um you know that really is
something that just didn't have a lot of
focus on it and um we thought we'd try
it out and it's been a great success and
like everything else you know once
something starts to work you really what
just want to make it better and see uh
you know what you can do with it
absolutely everybody comes out and
checks it out um it's a great event the
venue is really made for um professional
music and dancing and all that stuff so
it's it's great that um this uh this
party's been going really well okay so
who are some of the performers that you
can name that have been on stage already
and that are coming
uh well someone that we have coming next
week is um freddy fresco okay and we are
just announcing uh dj pope um who's
going to be coming soon too so okay some
really big actors and what are some of
the you know obviously you can walk in
and enjoy but there are some
reservations you can make some packages
you can enjoy as well that are special
to this night right absolutely we have
special packages that we put together
for this party um that offers some great
products like bacardi gray goose
delion tequila has been really
successful one for us and we're
we just have discounts for those those
bottle packages so all you can do is
just inquire online with us and we'll
take it from there latin music live
vibes vegas vibes bottle service you
can't really go wrong with that at
daylight where can people get tickets or
more information uh you can just go to
our website
daylightbeachclub.com all right nick
thank you so much kendall awesome to see
you all right rocky he has